oh my god what they're doing to the
internet right now as far as internet
search results is far worse than even i
had realized in my previous video i
showed what happens when you google
certain topics or any topic whether it
be something controversial or something
benign and how it will show hundreds of
millions and even billions of search
results but when you scroll over just a
few dozen pages it just stops dead in
its tracks and
upon doing some further experimenting
into this because i read many comments
and people asking what happens when you
use alternative platforms like
duckduckgo and others
so upon doing some experimentation i
found that it's even far worse than i
had realized and this is really
important because certain people had
some feedback saying that okay this is
nothing sinister this is nothing you
know conspiratorial it just has to do
with data and how the internet search
engines work
but let me just jump into this to show
you just how bad things truly are
involving the controlling of information
okay so here i am back at bing which is
the second largest search engine after
google youtube and here i am i just type
in this simple little date which we all
are aware of and as you can see we have
8.7 billion search results so let me
just scroll back down and do what we did
last time except for you're going to
find something far more disturbing than
the results just cutting off
so give this just a second and notice
that at the top every time i go to
another page they throw wikipedia at the
very very top
but start to notice some of these
recurring titles
ex-officer police officer gets seven
years in prison after mar-a-lago
searched users on pro-trump blah blah
blah blah blah so just wait for it
because you're going to see very quickly
the same thing over and over and over
again
look at this
mar-a-lago sorry it keeps highlighting
everything but look at this here
keep watching
after mar-a-lago users blah blah blah
from nbc news that's page 13 let's go to
page 15.
again wikipedia
go down
same article right here ex-officer gets
seven years
nbc news mar-a-lago golf course blah
blah blah the same one nbc news after
mar-a-lago blah blah blah go to page 17.
same thing look this article as well
from wikipedia january 6th look at this
over
and over
again look page 17 let's go to 19.
look at this
people were trying to criticize me in my
prior videos saying that you just again
you don't understand how the data works
it doesn't matter it's not showing you
billions of results you don't need to
see them anyways and people just
explaining away the situation no this is
far worse look it's gonna end at a
certain point like i showed you last
time if i go a few dozen pages in
go watch that previous video but this is
even worse than that this is quite
literally
shockingly worse than i had imagined
look it's the same articles
over
and over
and over again i'm paying 25 or page 25
going on a page 27. look same thing over
and over and over again page 29
same thing over and over and over again
do you get the point i'm not even going
to bother showing you how far this goes
i don't even care because well i do care
but i want to show you what happens
let's go to yahoo which i trashed on
last time
and you're going to see something look
at you see already searched for it so
watch this
about 130 million results far less than
bing or google but watch this let me
just scroll over page five let me go to
page seven
just wait for it i'm just going to go
several pages in and you might start to
see a recurring theme um
pay attention look at that same nbc news
uh result ex police officer get seven
years
wait for it because this one seems to be
mixing in other articles as well but
here we go
look the wikipedia page
look at these results
pay close attention look
these are all the same ones
totally different search engine look
same thing they're all the same how many
look we're on page 21 let's jump to 23.
look
same exact stuff all over again page 25.
look
this is disturbing i thought it running
out of results after a few pages you
know several dozen pages in was um not
just bizarre but disturbing as well
but i didn't actually look to read all
the different articles i made paid i
mean i paid attention to see that
they're all mainstream articles and that
was the point i made in the last video
look i'm 33 pages in it's the same
results
so this go to duckduckgo which is
supposed to be the good one right
well standby now what's interesting
about duckduckgo is that they don't show
you
the page or the results number but well
it will see look
they're more nuanced see hold on see
right here so i'm just gonna keep
hitting more results just laid out
differently you can see it said three
uh right here so you'll notice so let me
just keep going so let's go to page
four hold on a second be bear with me
because so notice how they're going to
throw wikipedia at the very top and look
we're already we're four pages in and
it's the same exact stuff as you were
seeing on bing and yahoo so hold on
let me go to page five look
same thing over and over again they do
mix in some other ones but look it's the
same ones
i don't i
i don't even know what to say guys this
is
if you're not concerned about this
then you may be lost and i'm not trying
to disparage anyone's way of thinking
now look okay so page seven
you see the wiki wasn't at the top a
couple new articles but that one isn't
or this one isn't this one the same so
let's just keep going just a little bit
further but this is supposed to be
duckduckgo here we go again
look
it's the same stuff
over and over again although i will be
honest this one seems to be throwing in
a couple other randoms but these are all
mainstream articles or outlets i mean
come on huffington post and everything
else
bear with me
so look
this one is better in that the mix in
other ones but there's still the
reoccurring recurring articles over and
over again all right we're on page 10.
look it keeps recycling this stuff over
and over again
oh my god all right well you get it i
mean
let's do one more page 11. see
same things over and over and over again
all these same articles between those
same search engines let me do it again
page 12 same exact ones
page 13
same exact
ones
uh
this is
just oh my god
did you expect it to be that bad i mean
again going back to my previous video
which you haven't watched it go go give
that a look because it'll save you a few
minutes to show you the experiment that
i had done it's one thing to go a few
dozen pages in and have the search
results just stop which i think is bogus
i don't like that and again it didn't
used to be that way but people could
explain it away all they want which is
all hold on this is this is a technical
standpoint this has to do with data most
people aren't searching that far if you
just get more detailed in what you're
searching for you'll eventually find it
which i basically had said that you have
to be very very specific
but this
demonstration this little experiment
shows exactly what i was saying which is
that they're putting everyone into these
boxes of information and we're all just
divided amongst each other i was making
the point that whatever the
controversial topic it it is that anyone
may be discussing you have these sides
that are so divided and sometimes i ask
myself i'm like how can people be so
divided there's enough information out
there to see that we're all just being
kept in these uh
methods of thinking but this in itself
really shows you that it's something far
worse they are just regurgitating the
same exact mainstream articles which are
probably paying these search engines to
be prioritized but how many dozens of
pages back do you have to go to see that
they have now limited all available
information
to any particular topic i mean in my
prior video i showed anything from
climate change january 6 to pancakes
this is concerning and everyone that
uses the internet which is everyone on
earth now pretty much
should be concerned about this as this
pertains to everybody so
i don't know i'll let all the tech
people put in their two cents and
explain this because i'm not a tech guy
i'm not pretending to know how this
works but what i do know is that this is
wrong for so many levels and to anyone
that doesn't see the long-term
consequences or where this is going to
lead
i mean i don't want to sound
patronizing but pick up a history book
bad things happen when you control
information everyone has a right to see
all available information to discern
what the truth is instead of having
people just show you like look these are
the options to choose from to
understanding the information it
involves cnn nbc cbs yahoo
oh it's just repeating all and over and
over and over again as i scroll through
this
i'm going to close this up my name is
jimmy corsetti my channel is called
bright insight hit the like button and
subscribe and leave a comment sharing
whatever your thoughts are on this i
want to whip out this video real quick
because when i came across this last
night by doing some further
experimenting i couldn't bite my tongue
i had to throw this out there as quickly
as i could so
here we go i'm going to close this up i
love you all do with this information as
you please but
take care everybody